Estados Unidos esperaba un aluvión de
cruces en la frontera al terminar el
título 42 y lo que se ha visto es un
descenso pronunciado A qué se debe esta
dinámica
Así es efectivamente era la preocupación
de ambas de ambos países de México como
el de Estados Unidos de que hubieran
tumulto de gente en los puentes
internacionales y efectivamente eso no
sucedió
más del 50 al 70% de las personas de
cruce irregular disminuyeron Esto se
debe también a la al miedo que tienen
ellos a ser castigados por cinco años
De no poder hacer un tratamiento
migratorio en Estados Unidos al entrar
de forma irregular
precisamente de los castigos más duros
que supone el título 8 le quería
preguntar de estos castigos más duros
para quienes crucen irregularmente a
pesar del descenso son muchos los que
siguen intentando cruzar a qué se debe
hay una falta de comunicación o
simplemente es imposible frenar este
fenómeno
es parte de todo
nos gana y nos rebasa la desinformación
la rumorología que cunde en las redes
sociales y en los grupos de chat de
todas las personas migrantes
nos rebasa el la desinformación y que
ellos hace más caso a los testimonios de
personas que han pasado de forma
irregular y han tenido el tino o la
suerte de de ser procesados o de o de
tener de estar en su destino y y esos
videos y esos testimonios son los que
permean más en el en el consciente de la
gente y el grado de desesperación que se
vive aquí en Matamoros están en un
campamento inhóspito insalubre en
condiciones infrahumanas muriéndose de
hambre sin dinero con una inseguridad
enfermos el tiempo se les prolongó para
sacar la cita en la aplicación de todo
Ese Conjunto de cosas perdió tanto la
población migrante que ya no pensaban
iban venían directo a cruzarse el Río
Bravo para entrar de forma irregular con
la esperanza de que los mil que entraran
uno o dos salieran elegidos para ser
procesados lo sabían lo sabían porque
las organizaciones y estábamos en pie de
lucha informando que era un delito
cruzar el río aparte de los decesos que
tuvimos de migrantes personas ahogadas
en el intento del sueño americano
perdieron la vida y a pesar de eso niños
mujeres embarazadas familias enteras
cruzaban y cruzaban fue un Éxodo de
migrantes Lamentablemente alto y que ahí
perdón sí ahí nos ganó la desinformación
y la y lo y la información informal que
permea mucho en ellos